today marks a big anniversary for an
iconic brand of gaming and entertainment
here in las vegas listen to this on july
1st
1976 frank fertitta jr opened a small
off-strip joint named the casino then it
was
bingo palace but you might know it now
as palace station casino
today the local favorite celebrates 45
years here in las vegas
we got an exclusive interview with some
of the people behind the station casinos
it all started 45 years ago
one small local with one big aspiration
we've all heard that behind every
successful story there's also
one full of hustle and sacrifice and
that's a true statement to one of the
most important people at palace station
casinos
i've had 13 jobs in this building so i
went from the front desk
20 26 years ago 27 years ago
to the gm of this property according to
david horn palace station casino's
general manager
the reason behind his success is the
people those who work with him at the
casino as well as their guests
this property has been a focal point of
this community for a very long time
and i think through especially it's been
magnified in the last few years given
all the events that have occurred
for us to emphasize that towards our
family towards our people towards our
community
and that's basically what the
celebration is 45 years of being in this
this location being in the city you have
to you have to celebrate that
with 45 years as part of the las vegas
life in community
palace station has had to adapt and
innovate through time while maintaining
its essence
that's where tal copperman comes in for
our entire lifespan as a company we've
always highlighted our team members a
lot of amazing stories
within our company we love highlighting
people so that was the first part
and then today we're shooting our tv
commercial which is
highlighting a very fun aspect of of our
company and
all of our team members so how does tao
tell the story of the life behind
station casinos and its people
while staying relevant in our ever
evolving technological world today
qn davonte house
nothing says celebration like a dance
party and that's exactly what tal
envisioned when they brought ticktacker
devonte house on board
a big dance celebration from the heart
of the casino its people
he created a dance for us and the team
members love at first they're very
nervous they don't know what to expect
but then
after five minutes of teaching them
they're all having a good time and
loving it and
i love catching people having a good
time and i think we all love that as a
company
it was crazy because like everybody's
everybody walked up at first and they
were like so like you know
nothing you know it's early in the
morning but then we start
getting to move it and i'm seeing smiles
everyone's having fun like
i feel like everyone everyone
their energy got brought up from this
and i feel like
the whole atmosphere is going to be
different after this
a very different atmosphere for sure
because that atmosphere would be nothing
without the palace station team members
and its guests
most importantly thank you thank you for
staying with us
thank you for being with us
being loyal thank you for making us as
great as we are thank you for
making us the property that we've been
over the last 45 years
45 years congratulations